[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
20-17 is in full gear new releases is
still bringing you the hottest games and
this week is packed with heavy hitters
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button to keep up with all the titles
you don't want to miss now let's get to
it shall we the survival horror
juggernaut is back with resident evil 7
biohazard this time around the scares
are all up in your face thanks to a new
first-person perspective if you play the
demo you'll already be familiar with
solving puzzles swinging axes and firing
guns from your new point of view for the
rest of you this is a chance to explore
an all-new still creepy mansion owned by
the bizarre Baker family and if you've
got a PlayStation VR headset you'll be
able to confront them face-to-face
resident evil 7 hits ps4 xbox one and pc
on Tuesday January 24th the second game
this week is based on a literal heavy
hitter Don Bradman was the greatest
cricket batter of all time and his game
series is coming to pc with don bradman
cricket 17 the improved career mode lets
you start playing cricket locally before
sending the ranks to become a true
professional and as you make your way up
team line-ups will change thanks to
injuries retirement sand trades for the
first time you can also create your own
stadium don bradman cricket 17 hit
consoles late last year but you can grab
it for pc on the 22nd kingdom hearts HD
2.8 final chapter prologue is a mouthful
and much like the title its content is
also pretty stuffed the game includes an
HD remaster of dream Drop Distance the
first time you'll be able to play it on
anything other than the 3ds it also
contains an epilogue to birth by Sleep
called a fragmentary passage and Kingdom
Hearts key back cover a new story told
through cinematics this final collection
bridges the gap to kingdom hearts 3 so
expect to come away with just as many
questions as answers you can dive in on
ps4 on the 24th
speaking of big RPG series the tales
franchise is back with tales of Bruce
area the new game is set in the same
world as tales of zestiria but told many
years before lead hero velvet crow and
her party must battle the demon blight
using the series trademark linear motion
battle system that means real-time
combat where you can fight using weapons
magic spells and special skills called
arts if that sounds up your alley then
you can check out tales of Bruce area on
ps4 ps3 and pc on the 24th and finally
there's another franchise getting a new
entry Yakuza 0 is a prequel to the whole
gang of titles and it's finally
releasing worldwide this time
protagonist Kazuma Kiryu and goro majima
find themselves in the middle of a power
struggle between several different mobs
you'll still get the same helping of
minigames missions and street brawls but
this time your heroes can use three
different fighting styles when taking on
a group of thugs the more you battle the
stronger you'll become and the more
money you'll shake down during street
fights Yakuza 0 hits ps4 on the 24th but
you can check out our review on gamespot
right now and those are the big games
will be playing this week as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for watching guys I'll see
you next week
[Music]